les parties du boulot c'est parce qu'il
n'y avait pas assez de travail pour tout
le monde n'a pas été par il n'est pas
parti parce qu'il travaillait mal nourri
son tour aujourd'hui il ya le le procès
nordahl hollandais qui démarre c'est
quoi le profil psychologique de dalles
le landais qu'il y avait beaucoup
travaillé sur lui c'est un fou furieux
mais il sait ce qu'il fait d'accord moi
j'ai parlé pendant deux heures hier avec
son ex copine en date
d'accord on lui a montré une vidéo du
soir de la disparition du caporal noyer
on le voit surgir à la boîte de nuit ils
savaient exactement précisément où
étaient toutes les caméras il était en
survêt avec une capuche sur la tête
il tournait la tête dès qu'une caméra
était braquée sur lui il savait très
bien ce qu'il faisait le mahdi il
ressemblait à un lion un prédateur en
quête de sa proie d'accord donc moi ça
fait ça fait trois ans maintenant que
j'enquête jour et nuit sur lui j'ai
découvert pas mal de choses sinon ils
peuvent qu'inquiéter pour le meutre le
maire de la petite maëlys il aurait
continué bourse et son parcours criminel
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est sacré je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de l'ex de
normal le landais une semaine avant la
disparition de la petite maelys elle lui
révèle qu'elle a voulu porter plainte
pour menaces de mort d'accord elle
arrivée au commissariat la police a
refusé de prendre sa plainte prétextant
que nordahl est un mec bien
ouais ça c'est factuel ça je vous le
révèle ça c'est pas sorti c'est
incroyable c'est ce que c'est ce qui est
sorti de mon entretien de deux heures
hier avec l'ex copine date de nordahl
cod des choses comme ça il y en a plein
malheureusement mon dossier l'aquadôme à
tous vous dit on et les capteurs nous
rejoindre là aujourd'hui on a à peu près
certain qu'il impliquait dans plus de
deux meurtres
voilà donc deux c'est sûr plus de
données sur tant qu'acteur affaire de
moeurs est sûre revoilà après il ya
combien d affaires ça je peux pas vous
dire par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il n'était pas seul ah oui ah
oui ah oui c'est à dire il a baigné dans
un environnement propice
tout ce qui est survenu donc ils avaient
des complices ouais il fréquentait une
club de boxe dans laquelle il ya des
pédophile notoire dont des gens qui ont
été condamnés dont un qui a été condamné
pour quatre agressions sur mineur et qui
a bénéficié d'un simple bracelet et il y
avait aussi d'autres gens qui l'a notre
site qui violait sa fille ait enfanté
saphique accouché sous x et ça des
exemples comme ça je vais dévoiler très
bientôt pour le deuxième
numéro de l'envers d un ferrer les
exemples comme ça il y en a à la pelle
des témoignages j'en ai à la pelle
saccage beaucoup de crasse toussaint
mais c'est fou normal c'était un soldat
ouais chose d'assez reçoit des ordres
bien sûr qu'ils les donnent exactement
vous pensez qu'il avait il été qu'il
était téléguidé c'est un point ouais un
soldat exactement comme pour fournir et
d'ailleurs fournir et à qui on a appris
à tuer qu'on relâche dans la nature qui
servit de nordahl le landais pour leur
grade le landais à la base c'est un
dealer connu pour sa dans son bled mais
accro à la cocaïne
en plus c'est un vendeur ils vous disent
quoi ses proches à nordahl de lourdes et
je peux pas faut que j'aille très
attention à ce que je dis parce que
sinon j'aime réveiller avec une plainte
demain mais sa famille n'est pas très
nette dans l'histoire parce que la
police le sait ça j'espère en tout cas
c'est l'apogée beaucoup de choses que je
m'apprête à voile a révélé des plus
grand tueur en série français pour vous
vous savez ya des cas de destruction de
preuves aussi dans cette affaire est un
gros coup de coeur bonjour à penser que
la sphère nordahl le landais elle est
bien plus important de ces pas
l'histoire d'un homme a dans l'histoire
de tout un groupuscule non non non cc
c'est pas du tout vous dites qu'on sait
rien sauf à penser qu'il ya des gens de
l'armée qui sont impliquées dont moi je
pense oui mais ils étaient les réponses
et we dance incroyable il ya un ami du
3è du 13e bca hautement comme le caporal
noyer donc est-ce que ça c'était pas par
exemple un règlement de comptes a bien
sûr le caporal noyer mais ça des
exemples comme ça il y en a il y en a à
la pelle mais moi j'aimerais insister
sur la destruction de preuves de la
charte des gendarmes c'est un des
exemples comme ça j'en ai plus le sac de
jean-christophe qu'on a retrouvés aux
fortes à mener on a appris à quelques
temps que il avait été détruit parce
qu'au bout d'un certain temps les
preuves il est garde pas alors on a à
l'heure actuelle on a des les nouvelles
informations qui disent qu avec l'adn on
va de mieux en mieux on trouve de mieux
en mieux
il aurait peut-être pu réétudier le
sache essayez trouvait justement là
petites gouttelettes qui traîne toujours
là où il faut pas belle le nom ça risque
pas là maintenant c'est fini ça qui les
ont même pas demandé si on voulait le
récupérer
rappelez vous de la gendarmerie qui a
été incendiée et concernant tous les
scellés sur la firme à l'hélice coups
sûrs voilà ça a été revendiquée par un
soi-disant opuscule groupuscules
anarchistes fait midi sans plus
tout le monde a pris ça pour argent
comptant mais incroyable